hey guys I am so excited right now
because I am on the set of the new Power
Rangers movie somehow they let me on the
set here
I love Power Rangers I still do I even
got a Power Rangers action figure I'm 30
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm with Becky G who is playing the
Yellow Ranger in this movie which
ironically is your favorite color right
yellow is my favorite color
yeah the Power Rangers was like the most
quintessential 90s series I think ever
would you say that this still has the
90s Vipers at a total update I think
it's a total update I think there's a
lot of things that we're doing whether
it be a scenery or just the way we're
dressing or how we're fighting that's
keeping like the true essence of Power
Rangers but it's definitely updated and
right and cool every Power Ranger has
their own unique weapons org costume you
got a great one but is there any Power
Ranger you're a little jealous oh no
because monster because you're the
bestest Limon yeah does everybody want
supply both the girls and the guys are
pretty badass in this film but who wins
out girls the guy I like the girls I
feel like obviously I'm going to do that
we so weird if I was like oh definitely
the boys I do like is the relationship
between Trini and Kimberly there's a
really nice friendship that kind of lost
them throughout the movie
I'm here with RJ the Blue Ranger in this
Power Rangers movie now do you feel like
a Blue Ranger in real life you're kind
of like you know I don't say the nerdy
type of you're the you're kind of a
smart one right well yes I mean I'm
smart in real life I'm just not as oddly
you know configured is really okay
that's all that's the only thing me and
Billy are two totally different people
alright what I am really smart and I
like to do things that might end up in a
very bad explosion but hey for the time
being explosions are fun yeah how close
is your red ranger to what we saw in the
original series I think I am an
extension of what we saw in the 90s but
I also think that my character is
relatable to current issues about what
what kids that age experience now
in the present day and I like to feel
that it's a reflection of both that time
period in this time period yeah in the
sense that kids then and kids now go
through the same stuff what are you most
excited for in this movie you know I'm
most most excited about seeing the movie
just yesterday I was thinking about all
the scenes in the movie and I mean like
all of this this is all this is real Wow
right and the makeup they put on us is
even worse so when I think about it like
these kids have been through a lot
the director warned us that he's going
to break us down we're going to suffer
before we get built up and that's how
kids are to go through the transition
phase and I think that's something
that's going to connect and that's
what's real now there's only one good
way to end a Power Rangers video and
that would be with the catchphrase you
ready one two three
Go Go Power Rangers I thought it's
morphin size four four sounds gota
[Music]
you
[Music]